we're told that given that h prime of
negative four is equal to zero
what is an appropriate calculus-based
justification for the fact that h has a
relative maximum at x is equal to
negative four
so right over here we actually have the
graph of our function h this is the
graph y is equal to h of x and we don't
have graphed the first derivative but we
do have graphed the second derivative
right here in this orange color h prime
prime
so they're telling us given that h prime
of negative four is equal to zero so
that's saying that given that the first
derivative at x equals negative four is
equal to zero and you can see that the
slope of the tangent line when x is
equal to negative four does indeed equal
zero
so given that
what is a calculus based let me
underline that a calculus based
justification for the fact that h has a
relative maximum at x equals negative
four
so this first one says that the second
derivative at x equals negative 4 is
negative
now what does that tell us if the second
derivative is negative
that means that the first derivative is
decreasing
which is another way of saying that we
are dealing with a situation where at
least at x equals negative 4 we are
concave
downwards
which means that the general shape of
our curve is going to look something
like this around x equals negative 4.
and if the slope at x equals negative 4
is 0 well that tells us that yes we
indeed are dealing with a relative
maximum point if the second derivative
of that point was positive then we would
be concave upwards and then if our
derivative is 0 there we'd say okay
that's a relative minimum point but this
is indeed true the second derivative is
negative at x equals negative 4 which
means we are concave downwards which
means that we are a
upside down u and that point where the
derivative is 0 is indeed a relative
maximum so let me sir that is the answer
and we're done but let's just rule out
the other ones
h increases before x equals negative
four that is indeed true before x equals
negative four we are increasing and h
decreases after it that is true and that
is one rationale for thinking that hey
we must have a maximum point assuming
that our function is continuous at x
equals negative four
so this is true it is a justification
for a relative maximum but it is not
calculus based and so that's why we can
rule this one out
the second derivative has a relative
minimum at x equals negative 4.
well it does indeed seem to be true
there's a relative minimum there but
that's not a justification for why this
is why
h of negative 4 or why we have a
relative maximum at x equals negative 4.
for example
this you could have
a relative minimum in your second
derivative but your second derivative
could still be positive there so what if
the second derivative was like that that
would still be a relative minimum but if
it was positive at that point then you
would be concave upwards which would
mean that at x equals negative four your
original function wouldn't have a
maximum point it would have a minimum
point and so just a relative minimum
isn't enough in order to know that you
are dealing with a relative maximum you
would have to know that the second
derivative is negative there
now this fourth choice h prime prime is
concave up
it does indeed look like the second
derivative is concave up but that by
itself does not justify that the
original function is concave up for
example well i could use this example
right here this is a potential second
derivative that is concave upwards but
it is positive the entire time and if
your second derivative is positive the
entire time that means that your first
derivative is increasing the entire time
which means that your original function
is going to be concave upwards the
entire time and so if you're concave
upwards the entire time then you would
not have a relative maximum at x equals
negative four so we would rule that one
out as well